let me introduce you to our first guest
of the morning here on policy issues
David Cay Johnston is on your screen
right now with the New York Times
convinced the New York Times several
years ago that the tax structure in the
United States was worthy of a beat and
he's been covering it since then and you
see his byline regularly in the
newspaper he's turned his reporting into
a brand new book called perfectly legal
the covert campaign to rig our tax
system to benefit the super-rich and
cheat everybody else we're gonna talk
taxes with him for the next 45 minutes
thanks for being here
well thank you for having me before we
get into some of the nitty-gritty of
this I thought it would be helpful for
our viewers to understand your view of
taxes and Taxation as it fits in a
society that kind of informs our
reporting well
taxes are at the core of our democracy
Oliver Wendell Holmes said 80 years ago
that taxes are the price we pay for
civilization I don't like taxes I don't
imagine you do but we have to have them
the this wonderful great idea the
greatest idea I think in the history of
mankind that we can govern ourselves and
solve our own problems has to be
financed through a tax system and so
then the questions become law who pays
taxes how our burdens distributed what
are the fair ways to do this and in our
society it's perfectly appropriate for
everybody to be trying to get our
democracy to benefit them in one way or
another so we have a tax system that
reflects those people who have been
seeking benefits from Congress on their
behalf I started writing about the tax
system because I felt that I never
understood exactly how it really worked
from what I read in newspapers and
magazines you know there was here's how
to say five dollars of this little tax
check over here and here's what some
politician said yesterday but how the
system really works is I did not
understand and so I have for the last
nine years been reading statistical
tables government reports all sorts of
documentation spending a lot of time
with experts writing about what happens
not what happens in the legislative
process but what happens in the system
once the laws are passed or in effect
and then the regulatory system and and
so how do we finance our government
is a is this book about whether or not
government spending should be reined in
or not no this book is not about what
government spending it is about both
parties and their role in the way the
tax system actually works
I mean basically I've done people's
homework for them I've said if you read
this and I've had people call me and say
I get it now I sort of had a sense of
these things but I didn't really know
exactly how they worked and now I get it
and I do this book through the lives of
ordinary Americans
I tell you about tax lawyers executives
a bureaucrat inside the IRS who figured
out a way for less than a hundred
thousand dollars to stop six billion
dollars or so a year of tax cheating and
couldn't get anything done about
business owners who refuse to withhold
taxes from workers paychecks and get
exposed on the front page of the New
York Times and they're not prosecuted
they're not gone after nothing happens
to them about people with offshore bank
accounts about corporate executives and
what the tax reasons that they want to
fly on personal travel in the company
jet I hope I can find it pretty quickly
here but I saw a poll in the newspaper
this morning about what people hope the
Congress will attend to when they came
back health care with number one by a
wide majority those who say they want
Congress to think about taxes came in at
nine percent is that never surprising me
this actually does I mean different
polls show different things and in fact
one of the things the book discusses is
how a question is framed in a poll
produces a great difference in the
answer Frank Luntz Republican strategist
told us he was the popularizer of the
term death tax for the estate tax
there's no death tax in America there is
an estate tax on the right to transfer
large amounts of wealth many some of
which has not ever been taxed and he
said that if he had been working for the
other side he would have popularized the
billionaire's tax so how questions are
asked
I don't deal essentially with polls I
deal with hard government data court
decisions things that are hard news many
of which I've had to extract and dig out
of the public record in all search of
obscure places around the country
courthouses and Tampa Florida and things
like
but is it your contention that if more
people understood the tax system that
that nine percent number would go way up
I think if more people understood the
tax system they would be making noises
to Congress about what they want and I
think that American the news media has
done a very poor job generally of
explaining the tax system number one
function is media is to tell you the
official version of events of what
happened yesterday the president said
this doctors did this this person got
arrested I do enterprise or
investigative reporting I think it was
Enterprise reporting I get up in the
morning I start reading a magazine
called tax notes and I say you know what
is out here that no one's writing about
that it's important for you to know and
then once I decide on something I have
to go sell my editors on it then I have
to do the really hard part which is I
got to find human beings whom this
happened to to make this come to life so
that you can understand it a point that
you make several times in the book is
that the tax structure that we have
right now is based on I can recall the
exact words and national industrial wage
based economy and we are now in a global
asset based economy we are moving from
we had a tax system that was pretty well
designed for the economy we had but
we're moving into a new tax system you
know all tax systems have to follow the
economic order and tax systems are very
important you if you lose your tax
system you lose your government you lose
we will lose our democracy if our tax
system fails the rosetta stone is a
document that grants tax relief they
carved it in stone they put it in the
village wall so yeah the the King and an
agrarian society could take part of your
crops in a pirate society the the leader
will take part of the booty in our
society we have to have a tax system
that in build zaur society that allows
us to perpetuate this wonderful idea of
America so that we can be free and
accomplish the things we're capable of
doing but the tax system has to
encourage that and not impeded one of
the other terms that should be defined
in this discussion is rich okay they're
lots of different ideas of what's rich
you know I try to keep in mind that by
any standard of the world I'm a rich man
even though I have to get up and go to
work here
wanting to support my family in the book
I divide people into groups as small as
the top 1/100 of 1% and I show in the
book that the principle beneficiaries of
the tax system are people who are in the
top 1% and mostly even within a small
group of the top 1% so well rich is a
somewhat florid phrase we did use on the
cover of the phrase the super-rich
meaning people who have enormous incomes
the 400 highest income people in America
in 2000 on average 174 million dollars
there are about 11 thousand people who
have a 10 million dollars or more of
income about a hundred and thirty
thousand with 3 million dollars in
organic and that's income is recognized
by the tax system not their real income
which I show in the book is in many
cases very substantially higher and can
you tell our audience after your
analysis what the net effect is on the
middle-class of President Bush's tax
cuts yes and President Bush's tax cuts
are a continuation of some ideas that
began under the Democrats actually in
the 80s and I show the history of this
but we are shifting the burden of
Taxation and America off the super-rich
and onto everyone else it is absolutely
true that the rich pay most of the taxes
in this country the top 1% make about 21
percent of the income and paid 37
percent of the income taxes on the other
hand starting next year after the
election millions of middle-class
families you can discover that their
Bush tax cuts are going to go away if
you you have a 97% likelihood if you
make seventy five two hundred thousand
dollars are married and have two kids
there's a 97 percent likelihood you will
lose some of your Bush tax cuts to
another tax a stealth tax or the
alternative minimum tax and a 42 percent
likelihood you will lose all of them and
all of the projections by people who've
looked at this show the same thing that
we are shifting the burden of taxes the
top 400 taxpayers whom I mention 174
million dollars of income each over the
years from 92 to 2000 the the percent of
their income going to taxes fell by more
than 20% the percent of income going to
federal income taxes for everybody else
rose by 18 percent that's one of the
many indicators of the shift in burden
that's going on first telephone calls
from Hercule
California yes hello good morning yeah I
am on the opposed Bush line I think he
Bush is going to go down as the worst
president in American history mr. K is
is right on the money
the problem is that whatever Bush says
is just a red herring when he compares
when he says these tax cuts are going to
the middle class they're not he cherry
picks his examples or who's going to get
these cuts it's just a an ongoing
example of the deceit this
administration has gone through with the
American public the Carnegie Institution
is could just come out with a report
showing how they deceive people you know
to send us into a rock for no reason now
they say it's a you know it's a
disposition of saddam but that's not
what the American people was told you
know we're told okay let me let me stop
you there because when I focus on taxes
this morning for shape the clock the
color I think it's one of many people
who they want to attribute to this party
order the other party something bad what
I show in the book is that this is
entirely bipartisan the average
congressman I've interviewed lots of
senators and congressmen claiming the
tax writing committees and many of them
could not keep up with my knowledge of
Texas now I'm just a reporter I've come
to the view that most congressman's
beliefs about the tax system as it
really is have as much to do with
reality as my third grandsons belief in
Santa Claus here's a headline from this
morning's Washington Post and politics
page Democrats pledge some tax relief
candidates focus on middle-class cuts
meaning that each candidate is in fact
Wes Clark has a piece into this
morning's Journal with his tax plan
overall what I gets to frame this into a
question if both parties are doing this
what what can people expect with regard
to structural change in the tax system
well if they don't know any more than
what they know now you're going to get
continue to get a tax system that
doesn't reflect the changes in our
economy and that alters the distribution
of burdens the principle problem
identifying the book is what I call the
political
class members of Congress all over the
place when you sit with them will tell
you that they spend an inordinate amount
of time raising money most of them don't
like it and but they also therefore are
thinking about this and every politician
says you cannot buy my vote you can only
buy my access well the only people who
have access to the people with money
what does classic economic theory tell
you should happen then you think about
the economic incentives in front of you
and for members of Congress it's what
can I do to these people who provide the
contributions that allow me to get
reelected so that's what's in the
forefront of their minds these are the
people who get to sit down and have long
conversations not hello how are you in
the local coffee shop during campaign
time and say here is this problem I have
and so the lens through which Congress
is viewing tax problems is heavily
distorted by this issue of access and if
you look at the kinds of the tax reform
that that when the Democrats had control
versus the kinds of tax reform that
happens on the Republicans what
distinctions do you see frankly not
really a lot the Republicans have have
focused very heavily on eliminating
taxes on capital there are a lot of
people would like to have a flat tax and
in the book I show how that would really
lower taxes on wealthy people because it
applies to wage income only and people
with capital assets would have their
assets tax but they personally would not
be taxed and I think that could have a
very serious deleterious effect on our
notions of freedom in this in this
society but both parties are doing
things that are based not on how the tax
system will benefit society as a whole
but on these myths that have been
inculcated and Riaan cockaded into our
society for a long time next call is
from Evansville Indiana good morning you
spoke of a flat tax and that has been a
thought of mine for some time that this
complicated tax code you're talking
about no one understands it and to try
to get into it just the each politician
puts a little different thing in it and
it's all totally incomprehensible and we
should have not just on wages but on
income a flat tax with a say a $25,000
per person deductible a family of four
is taxed on only what they make over
100,000 and whatever rate you set the
flat tax 37 percent so they would pay on
say they made one hundred and ten
thousand they would pay thirty seven
percent on the ten thousand a single
person would pay on on anything over
twenty five thousand and this would get
the politician you know the packs and
all the money giving everything is to to
influence the tax code it would clean up
politics tremendously and least in my
opinion mr. Dunson you write about who
benefits from complexity oh absolutely
wealthy people you know 777 more than
70% of Americans can fill out what
amounts to a postcard tax return now
they just take the standard deduction
the complexity primarily benefits people
who have lots of money it on one level
of benefits people who get deductions
for their their property taxes and
things like that their charitable gifts
but the most of the tax code and most of
the complexity has to deal with big
businesses and really rich people
getting special pleading favors San
Francisco good morning your officer
David Cay Johnston good mornings he
spent happy 25th anniversary first-time
caller
I just wanted to first of all thank the
guest for his wonderful ability to kind
of break down complex issues into easily
grasp well thank you components thank
you my question kind of goes I wanted to
elaborate on a point that just brought
up a few minutes ago about the
Democratic candidates tax plans and I
was wondering if you had given any
review to the specific tax plans if you
ever have any history of working
specifically with campaigns and if not
if you have any open advice to campaigns
to help them better craft the tax plan
that house would you reduce the tax
burden on the low to middle class well
I'm a reporter I don't I'm not involved
in politics and and I don't work in
Washington I mean I do a lot of the work
out of my home in Rochester New York
because of what the kind of work that
I'm doing as a reporter I have not read
any of the candidates tax plans
I hope the candidates read my book all
of them because I think that it will
help them understand how to
think about taxes in a different way
than we've seen happen next telephone
calls from Bethesda Maryland in the
Washington suburbs you're on the air
good morning good morning I'm calling to
explore further this tax inequity talk
about particularly concern about top 1%
you saying paying are earning 21 percent
of the income and paying thirty seven
percent of the taxes I think what a
burden the burden is on the high end of
it well if you if you look at it by that
measure that's exactly correct but
there's another way to look at it how
many pennies out of each dollar of
income are you paying in taxes and in
many cases family of people in America
making $60,000 have more pennies out of
each dollar taken out of their pocket by
government than people who make a
million dollars ten million dollars a
hundred million dollars a year in the
year 2000 those folks who made a hundred
and seventy four million dollars each
paid twenty two cents of each dollar in
federal income taxes their Social
Security taxes are in a relevancy at
that income level and have the Bush tax
cuts been in effect they would have paid
17 cents Americans overall excluding the
top 400 paid 15 cents out of each dollar
in income taxes the interesting 15 cents
living on any income and 20 and 17 cents
or 22 census was the actual case at 174
million dollars is another way you have
to look at the burden you have to the
wealthy have focused us on the 1% pay
most of the taxes issued that's only one
piece of the pie Gaithersburg Maryland
good morning Berg I made $40,000 three
years ago and they automatic the way the
art of people is unfair and I was
wondering what kind of taxes does our
senators and governors pay compared to
normal people
well everybody pays under the same tax
system with the same rules but the the
viewer makes a really important point
the IRS focuses in a trivial pursuit on
cheating by people who have wage income
you know you file a tax return now what
can we find that's wrong with it
we make almost no effort to find people
who don't file there are hundreds of
thousands of those people who are
wealthy and and some few millions of
them overall they make no effort to find
people who really investigate people who
are in control of what the government
knows about them America has two tax
systems separate and unequal one is for
wage earners whose income mortgage
deduction interest payments are all
reported to the government the other is
for business owners investors and
landlords who are in control of what the
government knows about them and we have
radically cut back on the tax police and
that's what the IRS our you know the
blue suits or the street cops the SEC
are the wall street cops the IRS they're
the tax cops and we have radically
cutback we have fewer than 3,000
criminal investigators at the IRS and
only about 12,000 auditors civil about
civil detectives for this entire country
we'll talk about you story you wrote
yesterday with the headline IRS to add
enforcement by reducing its clerical
staff yes well as we move to electronic
filing the IRS is going to be able to
shut down these things called the
pipeline when your tax return comes in
to one of these big processing centers
that are truckloads and truckloads of
them and they have specially built
little blond wooden tables that sort of
imagine when you were in school your
school table with a superstructure on it
and they open the returns up and they
process them and then they key punch all
this data back in not all of it about
40% of it back into the IRS computers
and as we get rid of that stupid system
and go to electronic filing those jobs
will be eliminated and they will get
more people the problem is Congress
keeps not properly funding the IRS so I
point out in the story that will they
say they're going to hire twenty four
hundred more law enforcement people will
see every time they've said that they
haven't hired very many people well
we're on that note with electronic
filing USA Today has the story this
morning that the IRS is planning to
track people who use the free file
system of electronics and people who are
either opting out of it some of the
software makers are saying we're not
going to participate in that's one of
them has said that and I think USA Today
this is a good example of a story where
the reporter doesn't deeply understand
what they're writing about you know all
the software companies love it when the
IRS
on the refund anticipation loans mostly
taken up by poor people there's an
indicator put on those and they have no
problem with that the purpose of this
indicator was of the IRS on a
statistical basis could say how many
people who are using free filing rather
than paying 14.95 to one of the tax
services for electronic filing which is
really thirty if you have to file a
state return how many of those people
are shifting over from paper returns or
how many were simply electronically
filing and paying a fee and are now
doing it for free that's all they wanted
to know my guess is and I have not
talked to this company but if you think
about it as a business proposition they
may have decided you know this free
filing thing is not worth it for us on
the margin it's not getting us any
worthwhile business we want out of it
here's a way to get out of it but in any
event it is clear that the industry
doesn't object to indicators on tax
filing per se and when they're tied to
individuals next calls from Bloomington
Minnesota good morning good morning my
question is that since world war ii the
United States was pretty much the sole
major capitalistic system in the world
now we're in a globally competitive
circumstance our tax system has always
been prone to manipulation because it is
too complex you have the tax accounting
in that industry being able to
manipulate it states for example that
have type have high taxes the businesses
simply move out you can't force capital
to be taxed because you end up like
athletes will ship their money overseas
to foreign markets so most of the
countries have consumption taxes that we
compete against they pay no tax in their
country or in the United States we tax
an income in a globally competitive
market or world that's increasing first
we saw the Germans and then the Japanese
now a lot of other countries we're going
to have to reduce our overall tax
burdens and have a more competitive with
the rest of the world otherwise we're
simply going to export capital to China
and to all of these other developing
countries so I agree maybe we could try
to beef up the IRS but the problem is is
that we're just not going to create
incentives in re
I mean to create the new businesses
we're losing in foreign global
competition and it's part of a whole
plethora of problems and so that was
just my point well I agree with the
caller I mean I think the that's my book
goes through in the way that it's an
effort to make people understand all of
these complex issues capital moves
freely across borders labor cannot by
its very nature even if the rules
allowed it and they don't and the tax
system needs to adjust for that the flat
tax was actually an effort to adopt onto
an income tax structure a value-added
tax consumption taxes the Europeans have
and the tax system as I said needs to
follow the economic order to be
successful and to maintain our democracy
when I go back to the IRS you write
about the experience of Charles with
Saudi they in the head of the IRS who
was the first non lawyer correct non tax
lawyer first businessman they're very
successful executive very wealthy man
very very competent executive and what
was his experience like and trying to
tackle the income tax code well what mr.
Rosati many people thought was brought
including me in the beginning was to fix
the computer system at the IRS because
he owned a computer company but what he
really did was focus on the culture
internally the IRS he reorganized the
place and you know in many government
agencies the worst thing you can do is
tell truth going up the chain of command
he changed that he said I want to hear
about problems we're going to address
problems the problem he had was that
Congress was cutting his budget steadily
and he had to make a choice and he would
never say this I would sit in his office
say come on Charlie Charles just
acknowledged this he didn't have enough
money to change the culture of the
organization to reorganize it so it
could be efficient and enforced the law
so we went from 10,000 tax liens a year
to fewer than a hundred tax liens and
basically if you if the police have to
pull everybody off the robbery squad to
write parking tickets which is what he
had to do right parking tickets and make
nice to people in the street guess what
bank robberies go up quite substantially
did his tenure coincide with the
hearings on Capitol Hill about the
runaway IRS agents well he was appointed
shortly before this and one of the
things I do in the book is show that
investigations by the New York Times tax
notes The Wall Street Journal others
have showed that
those hearings were basically bogus the
most explosive charges were not true
when they're investigated of course that
those hearings by law the IRS was not
allowed to defend itself what effect did
they have on the agency oh they had an
enormous effect on the agency one of the
stories that I won my Pulitzer Prize for
dealt with how IRS agents were all
intimidated it they passed a law that
says if you do any of ten things you are
must be fired well now almost nobody's
been fired and most of the complaints
are bogus but if you're a first level
supervisor in the IRS not an
organization known for having the best
managerial talent around especially at
the low levels and a tax professional
for a big firm start saying we're gonna
1203 you that's the technical term for
it and you're gonna end up under
investigation by the Internal Affairs
squad called tinta hey let's just you
know find a few items in this tax return
and close down and let's move on here
and there's even a phrase for it some
IRS agents use they call it audit light
and the beneficiaries of that are the
most aggressive people who can hire the
savviest folks and one of the the
stories that I tell is about an IRS
executive who was not gonna play this
game he was going to enforce the tax law
fairly regardless of your political
connections or income status and how he
was fired and gotten rid of
next is Dracut Massachusetts Susan on
the 25th date of restoration c-span I'd
just like to say thank you also to the
cable industry for providing c-span
c-span my opinion has been a major force
and bringing objectivity back to
reporting prior to my watching c-span I
remember hearing reporters say
objectivity was not necessary in
reporting just that one would not bring
it their bias to their writing to their
reporting itself and c-span is the most
objective reporting means in existence
today mr. Johnson my question for you is
and my the previous caller kind of stole
my thunder I had a question about
consumption spending consumption taxing
as compared to taxing on your income
previously a couple of Representatives
did have some programs out there for
that kind of taxing and they were on
c-span and actually took some of their
numbers and plugged into my
I income and even using payments made to
services as something that I would be
taxed on my income did come out some
small percentage lower and at the time I
paid about a total of 23% in my taxes
overall out of my paycheck and is this
something that you see yourself as
thinking of a better system and what are
the chances of ever having this change
considering it would help clean up the
IRS if it eliminated
thank you very much retire well first of
all you're never gonna eliminate the IRS
you would go to a national sales tax
there'll be national sales tax
enforcement people all tax systems have
to have an enforcement mechanism but I'm
not an advocate of any tax system what
I've done in this book is try to say to
people here is you know the high priests
of tax have controlled the information
about how the system really works the
first caller said it's incomprehensible
you know what it's not incomprehensible
but it's taken me ten years of hard work
to make it comprehensible what I've done
in this book is tried to say to people
here's how the system really works and
I've got numbers all over the place
you're gonna hear from lots of different
voices and points of view and the object
was to give people a base of knowledge
so they can choose what they want to do
that's what our democracy is about the I
contend that the super-rich have rigged
the tax system for their benefit there
is nothing wrong with the super-rich
trying to rig the system for their
benefit the problem is that the middle
class America is not involved as the
ministers it should be in politics and
it's not getting its interests advanced
in our system the poor aren't getting
their interests advanced in our system
in a democratic system everybody has to
be involved or a few people are gonna
hijack the system Newbury Massachusetts
no Barre Massachusetts
oh yeah we are a consumer orientated the
industry and I was great when we
manufacture 90 percent of our products
now we're importing that much I would
suggest that we thought the taxing that
say five cents on gasoline and start
dropping the taxes at sea on telephone
on our theater tax on a small
restaurants why should the two family
working have to pay taxes on what they
eat
paalam our Walmart import 90% of their
stuff these things should be taxed thank
you
a statement on the app I don't know if
you can pick this person but on the
average middle American when you add up
all of the taxes they pay actually the
Census Bureau has done some work on this
and it's actually very assuring me look
at all taxes economists divide people
into quintiles fifths or deciles tenths
or fractals a fraction one percent I do
a lot of fractals at the top 1% showing
how concentrated things are at the top
1/100 of 1% level when you break people
into quintiles
the bottom quintile pays about 18
percent of its income in taxes of all
kinds the top quintile 19 percent so
when you look at the whole tax system
federal income tax Social Security
Medicare jobless tax guys everything
excise tax the sales tax on the internet
tax on your telephone you put it all
together we sort of have a flat tax
based on the larger numbers now as you
get into that up for quintile that would
fall off and that's one of the principal
points I make in the book is that we are
over taxing people who make fifty to
five hundred thousand dollars a year and
we are taking that money through
explicit government policies and using
it to allow the rich to pay less in
taxes the smaller their share of tax
burden the more you can save and as
we've raised taxes on the middle class
another set of government sistex has
shown guess what savings has fallen at
the same time because the money people
would have saved is going to taxes if
you taxed if the government taxed that
top quintile this the smallest sliver at
the same rate as the rest of the people
paying taxes and they've paid their fair
share in other words how much money
would were down to the Treasury
you know I don't have the number to top
my head but let me tell you how enormous
it is the top twenty seven thousand
people in America have as much income as
the bottom ninety six million so a
number the what a third of an audience
at Redskins Redskins Stadium something
along that order have as much money as
everybody who lives Kansas West plus
Iowa
so if income for example West Clark is
in his article suggesting that if we tax
the super-rich fairly it will put ten
billion dollars in the Treasury is there
a way that he would have gotten that
number somehow if you're applying it to
the top one-tenth of one percent that
doesn't strike me as a as a big number
it strikes me as a conservative number
we know that the the top 400 taxpayers
because had they been taxed in 2000 at
the same rate they were in 1993 1992 I'm
sorry before the Clinton tax increase
1992 would have paid eight million
dollars a year more each in taxes Port
Charlotte Florida welcome to our
conversation with David Cay Johnston yes
good morning I have a question about 20
years ago back in the early eighties my
wife worked for the fifth largest oil
company in the world and one of her jobs
as a CPA was to meet with the IRS agent
and take his request to her supervisor
as to what they wanted to look at and he
would either approve it or disapprove it
do you know anything about this type of
behavior going on in the corporate world
thank you well the biggest corporations
in America are audited all the time the
current Commissioner is moving quite
quickly to narrow the scope of those
audits furthering a trend the previous
Commissioner had begun but the way it
works is that the companies of course
generally the some companies are totally
cooperative but many companies have a
policy of not wanting to cooperate with
the IRS the IRS agents there's often
team of them are often given desks in a
company they then say well we have your
tax return here and we want to see this
document in that document to justify
these expenditures the typical game
played by those companies that don't
want to cooperate is they stall install
and delay and come up with reasons not
to produce things and say basically you
want to file for a subpoena or what's
called a summons to get it you go right
ahead there's a lot of different
strategies by companies but the
fundamental issue is that the auditors
have to ask for that data the company
doesn't just hand it over to
I want to go back to my question
regarding West Clark cuz I want to quote
him correctly and is is opinion piece in
The Wall Street Journal today that the
point starts out talking about the tax
codes complexity and allowing
sophisticated filers to take advantage
of it but he closes that paragraph by
saying cracking down on corporate
loopholes will save Americans ten
billion dollars a year
next telephone call is from McPherson
Kansas good morning you're on for David
Cay Johnston I'm one of those
middle-class taxpayers from Kansas West
thanks for c---span you serviced my
alarm clock almost every morning I
really an economist recently make this
statement you never cut taxes you only
defer them appreciate you comment on
that well it's a principle in tax
lawyers teach their clients that a tax
deferred cost less so if you can defer
tax for thirty years because of the time
value of money it's the equivalent if
not not paying it and as a practical
matter the likelihood that the IRS is
going to know 30 years later and there's
any records to support you're paying the
tax is tiny on the other hand a tax you
pay before it needs to be paid as a much
more expensive tax this year Americans
will pay 50 percent more in Social
Security taxes than will be paid out in
benefits that fifty percent is not being
used to pay down the federal deficit as
was promised so that the government
could borrow money when the boomers
retire instead it's being spent to help
finance tax cuts for the super-rich so
you're paying an extra tax today to
benefit the super-rich Moynahan when the
law was passed said this was the biggest
thievery of all times
this is what the book looks like we're
talking about this morning it is
available in bookstores all around the
country right now and your publisher is
penguin portfolio and I want to tell you
a little bit about our guest this
morning who it covers the tax beat at
the New York Times and he is a Pulitzer
Prize winner born in San Francisco and
has studied economics and law at the
University of Chicago also has studied
at Michigan State and San Francisco
State University has worked at the Los
Angeles Times Detroit Free Press and San
Jose Mercury News and he has eight tax
deductions of his own at home well know
they're grown 707 of my children and
this book is the number one nonfiction
book at Amazon right now and that making
the point more clearly is the father of
eight children next telephone call for
David Cay Johnston is from Punta Gorda
Florida go ahead please the interview he
said that the lower percentile people
paid more taxes under Clinton and the
upper twenty-foot the upper group paid
that 20% what I would like him to
explain that when under Clinton the
upper percentile were paying what from
32 to 33 they want 39% he call I'm
really glad you asked that question
because it's a great example of wire up
this book we raised the marginal tax
rates under Clinton the marginal tax
rate doesn't determine how much you pay
it just determines how much you pay on
the margin and under Clinton we also
passed the Republican sponsored
middle-class tax relief bill of 1997
that and some other bills actually were
huge boons to the very rich and that's
what cut their taxes very substantially
was the 1997 tax cut bill it had a
provision in it that Lee Shepard of
Texas magazine said as a result it
should be called the drug dealers and
mobsters Tax Relief Act of 1997 because
of prohibited the IRS from doing certain
activities but while marginal rates were
raised in 93
capital gains rates were cut in 1997 and
so the data I have I make these numbers
up these are the official government
numbers of the United States of America
next Greensboro North Carolina good
morning hello yes sir we're talking
taxes you have a question well I'd like
to point out to mr. Johnson there it's
pretty obvious where he's coming from
obviously a liberal but Hamilton in in
Federalist 21 I think it was advocated
that the best the first tax for the
central government to raise money would
be a consumption tax there is and you
know miss Johnson I'm sure
a bill in Congress has been there for
two or three years called Fair Tax which
is a national sales tax proposal and why
haven't you expound it on that a little
bit from them for the viewing audience
and and people who are interested in it
could go to Fair Tax org or you can dial
one eight hundred and one other point
I'd like to make is you implicit I think
of what you're saying about the rich
people is that they somehow don't
deserve the money I know I died sir sir
I've never said that it's not in my book
sir I've never said that it's not in my
book I don't I specifically actually
said on this show sir that there's
nothing wrong with wealthy people
seeking favours from Congress everybody
does that it's perfectly okay to do that
I don't have any antipathy toward rich
people and I frankly consider myself to
be a wealthy man well you are as much
money as you want to the federal
government and so are all the other rich
but I'm not calling for sending more
money of the found government's all
right there's nothing in my book that
calls for sending more money to the
federal government I don't call for
raising taxes on anybody in my book sir
making assumptions you start off with an
assumption about my political views
which are wrong and I'm not gonna go to
what they are but they're very wrong and
you know what I've done in this book is
laid out for people how the tax system
works from official sources and
documents and people in the government I
don't promote any agenda not in favor of
any particular tax this viewer happens
to be in favor of a national retail
sales tax tax economists across the
board have identified the problems with
doing that there are you could do that
it will not eliminate having the tax
police you know if I were from the
national retail sales tax bureau its
excuse me that's a very nice suit do you
have a sales tax receipt for that suit
oh well I'm sorry let me get off the
handcuffs all tax systems have problems
all tax systems involve choices when
government imposes a tax it makes
choices about who will prosper and who
won't prosper how investments will be
made and I'm not arguing for any tax
system I'm saying to people if you want
to understand how the tax system really
operates not what the politicians say
not what the news media has been telling
you generally this book will allow you
to understand that and come to your own
conclusions about what you think that we
ought to do earlier you talked about how
a few members of Congress really
understand the tax code who has the best
grasp of it in Congress Oh Wilbur Mills
and he's dead I tried to talk to Senator
Roth one day about the late Senator Roth
who held the hearings in 1997 about a
tax issue and it was quickly apparent
that he did not understand and this
man's a lawyer and maybe it's
unreasonable to expect members of
Congress to have the kind of knowledge I
have when I spend my whole life for ten
years now focusing on this because I
wanted to understand it for myself and I
wanted people to understand and it is
difficult to understand I don't don't
dispute that thank goodness I wouldn't
have a way to make a living the but most
members of Congress are guided as the
caller who just called in was by these
sort of myths we have this tax is
favored by liberals this this tax is
favored by poor people and in my book
one of the things I point out is that
all the rich don't want to cut their
taxes there are wealthy people who think
the tax system is unfair to the poor
there are poor people who think the tax
system is unfair to the rich people have
lots of different views about these
things my book is about how the
structure actually operates when all
these pieces fit together Newburgh New
York good morning good morning my
question my question is there are
national companies advertising that they
will help you with your IRS problems so
if you a large percentage of the dollars
owed I was wondering if you had an
opinion about the effectiveness of the
company there is no free lunch one of
the first things I heard when I went to
the University of Chicago graduate
school of economics there is no free
lunch if you are bankrupt or in
technically insolvent not literally
bankrupt but in fact insolvent you may
be able to settle your tax debts with
the IRS if you're one of the people whom
they're pursuing and by the way among
one category of tax cheats partnership
tax cheats 78% of the people aren't even
asked to pay up there are lots of people
who are not being pursued but if you're
getting pursued they're not gonna stop
pursuing you
you're going to have to pay or make
arrangements to pay they do have things
called offers and compromise if somebody
wants a four thousand dollar
multi-thousand dollar fee upfront from
you walk away as we close here for
someone who has spent a decade of their
career and now has a book on the market
about this what would be the best
outcome for you of all this work and
brainpower you've put into this area
well if frankly I mean I hope a lot of
people read this book because I think
that if they do we will have a more
intelligent debate about the tax system
and I think out of the wisdom of
everybody in America we can come up with
a better system I don't know how to
create a better tax system I don't have
the capacity to do that all I have is
the capacity to identify how the system
really works and then people can decide
what they want to do I do hope though
that we we spend more time thinking
about democracy to the extent that
people worry about who this would that
actress or actor was sleeping with last
night or running around within a bar
instead of how our democracy works we
are ceding to those people who have a
real interest and it maintained an
interest in how government affects their
finances to them and for democracy to
work you have to decide to be a citizen
you have to do the work you have to pay
attention you got to read more than one
newspaper you know I subscribe to the
National Review and the Weekly Standard
and the nation and the Atlantic and
Harper's and a whole variety of
publications across the board because I
learned things from the National Review
that I'm not going to learn if I read
the nation and people need to spend time
thinking about what kind of society they
want and telling their politicians going
to vote talking to their friends and
neighbors making sure that our democracy
survives this is the most important
business we have and it affects our
children our grandchildren in the future
as to how we maintain our free society
and what I try to do is people's
homework form thank you for being here
thank you the book is available widely
in bookstores both the bricks and mortar
store or on the internet David Cay
Johnston is the author of the book
perfectly legal it's about the US